okay so as you guys know  i don't even got to say like what i'm  talking about because the picture okay  so tell me if i got anything wrong when  jada had her entanglement with august  okay  august stayed with their family and he  was like addicted to drugs and they were  helping him and then she starts sleeping  with him when he's 20 and she was 45 and  from what i understand she she knew him  when he was younger and i don't i don't  know what age but it just gives me like  grooming vibes  like 20 20. now imagine if will smith  okay did the same thing  one of willow's friends okay  that was 20 he's 45 and he starts  hooking up with her and she's addicted  to drugs do you feel like will smith  would have been canceled or there would  have just been a different energy about  it  because i didn't realize that he was 20.  it just gives me predator vibes i don't  know but let me know what you think in  the comments